Kingslayer a word every man and woman in
Westeros spits at me though many can't
even name the king I slayed I understand
to them I'm a symbol of everything
they'll never have and a warning that'll
never apply so they can lower me from
the safety of their small lives but when
a dog goes mad we put it down why not a
king I was never supposed to be on the
Kingsguard
Oh as a boy I dreamed of the white cloak
like all boys but I was heir to Tywin
Lannister hand of the king if he forbade
the tides the waves would cease then I
was 15 and my father was congratulating
me on my new knighthood in the red keep
I wonder if that was the last time he
was proud of me that night there was a
knock on my door and I opened it to find
my sister Cersei disguised as a simple
serving girl and seen her since my
father taking it to court when she was
12 she had grown up as had I she told me
that my father planned to marry me off
to Lysa Tully but she could arrange for
the king to raise me to the Kingsguard
so I could stay in the city with her all
I had to do was agree
I made the obvious objections our family
our Father Casterly Rock until she asked
isn't a rock you want or me
come morning she had my consent I would
join the Kingsguard for her I would
force where my lands and title for her I
would forsake our family for her soon a
royal raven commanded my father to
present me to the king during the great
tourney at Harrenhal to say my vows
my father he erupted in fury he could
not object openly but he resigned the
hand ship and return to Casterly Rock
taking Cersei with him instead of being
together Cersei and I exchanged places
then everything started to fall apart at
Harrenhal King Aerys made a great show
of my investiture I knelt before women
gleaming arm and swore the oath of the
Kingsguard when Sir Gerald Heights her
raised me up and put the white cloak on
my shoulders her raw wind up from the
crowd
I admit despite my father's anger I was
happy and foolish that very night Harry
soured commanding me to return to the
refugee guard the Queen and little
prince v-series
so Gerald offered to take that suit
himself so I might compete in the Tony
but Aerys refused he'll win no glory
here the King said he's mine now not
Tywin's he'll serve as I see fit
that was when I understood
it was not my skill ballad that had won
me this honor Mad King had chosen me to
spite my father and steal his heir I
wanted to rip off the white cloak but it
was too late a Kingsguard serves for
life so I upheld my health confined to
the red key where Varys could watch me
and whether headsman could find me if my
father displeased the King we served the
Kings pleasure as he burned Rickard
stark alive and strangled his son
inciting the rebellion I defended the
King's honor against torches as his
generals lost battle of the battle with
Robert I kept the key sequence where his
Pyromancer said caches of wildfire
beneath King's Landing I gave the King
counsel and my father's army was at the
city gate and grand maester pycelle lied
that my father had come to same for me
many forget that I also tried to defend
the King from heart when the Lannister
soldiers poured through the gates it
fell to me to hold the red keep as the
only Kings got in the city I knew we
were lost the sense of Aerys asking his
leave to make terms the man came back
with a royal command
bring me your father's head if you are
no traitor
Ares would have no yielding as
Pyromancer was with him my messenger
said I knew with that mountain Aerys
Targaryen was alone in his throne room
when I found him picking at his captain
bleeding hands the fool was always
cutting himself in the iron throne burn
them burn them he kept muttering Aerys
have decided to let Robert be king after
all over the charred bones and ashes of
King's Landing he must have thought his
Parham answer was named after obey Him
but I'd killed him a few minutes before
in the courtyard as I approached the
throne sanity flashed behind the Kings
eyes for a moment just long enough to
read the log in mind
huge and the Royal mouth drooped opening
shot he turned and ran a single trust
was all it took to end the greatest
dynasty the world had ever seen
beneath the empty eyes of the depth
dragons on the walls The Last Dragon
Kings wield like an pick and shat
himself so easy I thought my king should
die harder than this my father's Knights
burst into the hall in time to see the
last of it so there was no way for me to
banish in it some brackets steal the
glory of blame I knew at once when I saw
the way that looked at me it would be
blamed Lannister No I've been one of
Paris's Kings go I commanded them to
announce that the Mad King was dead and
to spare all those who yielded they
asked me if they should proclaim a new
king as well I knew what they meant
would it be my father or Robert
Baratheon or maybe the child Viserys
who'd fled to Dragonstone but a gariand
boy king with my father's hand to rule
in truth I thought of how Ned Stark and
Robert Baratheon would howl at this end
to that great heroic war and I was
tendered the night glance down again at
Ares his life's blood oozing from the
wound and pooling on the floor around
him
proclaim who are you bloody well like I
said I climbed the steps of the iron
throne and sat on it with my sword
across my knees waitin to see who would
come to claim the kingdom